well I hope you all had a great weekend
we had a pretty good weekend well I'll
tell you one thing that we did over the
weekend my kids had two more Easter egg
hunts to attend actually the second one
was rained out so they postponed it for
it for next weekend
so we're gonna stretch this into a third
week they had two or three Easter egg
hunts leading up to Easter and it's this
whole this is what I was complaining to
my wife about it said it seems like our
kids somehow celebrate every holiday
numerous times like for Halloween they
go trick-or-treating probably 12 or 13
different times they're 12 or 13
different trick-or-treating events
Christmas they have about five or six
different Christmas get-together is
where they get presents somehow they
celebrate their birthdays multiple times
between all the different family members
and friends and everything is it just my
kids who do this or is this is this it's
just the thing now that all kids do
where you get words every holiday
becomes a two or three month long ordeal
when I was a kid we had one celebration
for each holiday if we were lucky and we
definitely only went Easter egg hunting
once and we didn't get candy in the
easter eggs either there were little
slips of paper with chores we had to do
that's what was in our Easter eggs and
we did our Easter egg hunt in the snow
in January and our bare feet and we
liked it damn it kids these days I'll
tell you what very spoiled all right
there's a lot to talk about today and
before we get to that speaking of kids
want to mention one quick thing about
education you know this year nearly
seventy billion dollars of taxpayer
money will be spent on public education
yet a new report finds that just two and
five American students will actually be
ready for college by the time they
graduate so that's a lot of money that
it would seem as being wasted many
people many of you I'm sure are
searching for a school with traditional
values that help students to develop
strong foundations in math and science
and English in American history but that
also teaches kids how TIF they kind of
think critically rather than just what
to think and if that's what you're
searching for then your search is over
freedom project Academy is
accredited online school built on
judeo-christian values and classical
curriculum for students from
kindergarten all the way through high
school with freedom project Academy
we're talking about a complete
interactive educational experience where
students attend live classes online with
other students from across the country
Freedom Project Academy provides live
and recorded lessons homework tests
tutoring grades transcripts you get all
of that and there are a lot of other
advantages too by the way it's being
online like you don't you don't have to
worry about eating in the cafeteria if
you're a kid so you avoid the politics
of who do you sit with who don't you sit
with you don't get you don't have to
deal with those little square pizzas
with cardboard crusts and ketchup for
sauce with the cheese flavored styrofoam
on top sides that's good to go to
freedom for school dot-com and request
your free information packet today
that's freedom for school calm and don't
forget to subscribe to their weekly
podcast the dr. Duke show available on
iTunes and more take back control of
your kids education freedom for school
comm freedom for school comm freedom for
school dot-com
all right another horrific shooting over
the weekend not just not just another
shooting but another synagogue shooting
specifically there were multiple
injuries one fatality that victim Lori
Kay the the victim who died sadly is a
hero who jumped in front of the bullet
to save her rabbi apparently truly a
courageous woman as I you know we were
talking about something last week I
don't remember what it was but I made
the point that words like hero and
courageous are way overused these days
and tragically so because they blunt the
impact of those words when it comes time
to actually use them appropriately like
in in this case and she wasn't the only
hero by the way another man chased the
gunman out of the the synagogue after
his gun jammed
and then another man came in a off-duty
Border Patrol agent came in and fired on
the vehicle to try to
you know take out its tires before you
drove away and got away so I mean this
is this is apparently a synagogue that
was attended by some incredibly
courageous people and it's because of
their courage that the deranged coward
who carried out this attack did not
succeed in inflicting the kind of damage
that he wanted obviously one loss life
is a terrible tragedy but I think the
heroes in this case prevented the
tragedy from multiplying and those are
the people that I would prefer to talk
about you know as for the anti-semitic
scumbag coward who did this well what
can you really say about him other than
what I just said anti-semitic scumbag
coward he doesn't deserve to have
anything else said about him really and
anti-semitism is a scourge that infects
both the right and left it is a plague
and it needs to be eradicated and the
plague as we have seen goes beyond
anti-semitism I mean just in the just in
the last couple of months we've seen
attacks on synagogues we've seen attacks
on mosques we've seen attacks on
churches many people dead and for what
you know these were all people who are
simply going to worship going to
practice their religion in peace but it
seems that increasingly there are those
who don't want you to practice your
religion in peace no matter what your
religion is and the people in that camp
are numerous and their numbers are
growing and so pray for our world folks
it is we are heading into dark places we
are already in dark places I'm afraid
all right the website I wrote about this
on Friday and I wanted I wanted to
mention it here because it is a
horrifying and heroin and harrowing
story that I think needs to be discussed
the website reason reason.com had a
report about the months-long saga of
corruption and abuse that a family
suffered at the hands of law enforcement
and Child Protective Services in New
Mexico
and it's if you go over to reason.com
you could read the whole article I would
really recommend it I will briefly
summarize it but it's worth reading the
whole thing and getting all the details
which I don't have time to provide all
of them right now
so the allow their family the loud their
family of New Mexico they found
themselves in the in the crosshairs of
Child Protective Services after a
teacher at the four year old daughter's
school claimed that the girl reported
that she'd been sexually abused by her
father and also her seven-year-old
brother now fast forwarding to the to
the end of the story here for a minute
the district attorney would eventually
decline to move forward with the case
because there was no evidence whatsoever
and the child's story kept changing
wildly and included a number of
obviously fantastical details and the
father passed multiple polygraph tests
and it's likely that the girl was really
just describing her father helping her
on the toilet helping her wipe or
something on the toilet which is
something that every parent has done for
their three and four-year-old kids many
times so that's that's what would happen
at the end but in between the initial
report from the girl if we can call it
that if we can call it a report you know
and not just a story but in between that
and the DA's decision to drop the whole
matter the allow their family was was
ripped apart the children were put in
foster care the five the father was
fired from his job he was labeled a
child rapist by the media his pictured
name were plastered on the plastered on
the front pages of the local newspapers
the young girl was subjected to lengthy
and incredibly invasive exams the the
the son the seven-year-old son was was
also interrogating the family was forced
to shell out three hundred thousand
dollars in legal expenses and
the accused father and his wife were
summarily stripped of all parental
rights not to mention their Fourth
Amendment rights and their Sixth
Amendment and Eighth Amendment basically
all of their rights went out the window
for many months based on something that
the DA would eventually say is
completely baseless now the most
frightening aspect of the story is the
malicious and underhanded yet
unfortunately familiar manner with which
the Child Protective Services and law
enforcement approached this case they
basically decided from the outset that
Adam louder the the father must be
guilty because who's ever heard of a
four-year-old child making up a story
right mean like that I guess that never
happens and so they treated him like a
child raping felon from the very
beginning these agencies were clearly
interested in establishing guilt by
whatever means necessary
not ascertaining the objective truth but
just finding guilt that's what they
wanted to do and they had the advantage
of a system that automatically turns
entire families into Ward's of the state
as soon as someone in government decides
that someone in that family may have
done something bad
so after initially being contacted by
the school the police forced their way
into the family's home without a warrant
they forbade the mother Jessica from
even speaking to her children to explain
what was going on eventually the kids
would end up in foster care
they were briefly returned to Jessica's
custody now the father was was not
allowed to see his kids at all for
several months he was sent off somewhere
across town but she she'd that the
mother also had custody removed briefly
she had custody restored but she had to
have her parents move in with her to be
safety monitors to make sure that she
wasn't abusing her children but then the
children were removed from her mother's
custody again once Child Protective
Services got wind of the fact that the
safety monitors which would be the
mother
parents were apparently sympathetic to
Adam and didn't believe that he was
guilty and so for some reason that meant
that they were no longer fit safety
monitors you know monied the whole
report I as I was reading it and often
when I read these stories about these
horror stories about Child Protective
Services I think about the book The
Gulag Archipelago which I've mentioned
before soul journey Stearns magnum opus
about the Soviet labor camp system and
as I was reading this report I kept
thinking about the Gulag Archipelago
because there are some real
uncomfortable resemblances there where
you know innocence and their story is
not unique
this happens a lot where you've got
innocent people innocent mothers and
fathers who discover that they basically
have no rights and no presumption of
innocence once the folks at you know in
this government agency decide to come
knocking it was the same thing in the in
in in in the Soviet Union where if the
government decided that you were guilty
of something you had no rights and they
were going to prove that you were guilty
one way or another they were gonna find
evidence they weren't looking for any
indication of innocence they'd already
decided you were guilty and now it's
just a matter of building a case and
anything that doesn't fit with the case
they're building they just throw throw
it out you know Chuck it to the side
this is the kind of nightmare scenario
that every parent dreads and it could
happen to any one of us if you're a
parent it could happen to you I mean
with the way the system is set up if
your child goes to school with a story
that she made up in her head or repeat
something that she heard from her friend
or for whatever other reason said
something that accidently implicates you
as an abuser or worse then you could
lose your kids just based on that there
doesn't have to be any other evidence in
the case of this family and these
parents
there was no other evidence none they
found nothing
but they their kids still ended up in
foster care I mean think about that you
know I think about with my own kids my
my five-year-old daughter she she likes
to you know as five-year-old kids will
often do she likes to make up stories
especially about her brother to try to
get him in trouble so she will she will
erroneously claimed that her brother her
twin brother punched her in the head and
they do smack each other and stuff like
as siblings do especially twins but I've
never seen my son punch anyone like
closed fist just walloped I've never
seen him do that least of all to his
sister and but she'll you know she just
says that sometimes and so I have to try
to work with her and that you don'ts if
it's not true you don't say it but what
if my daughter went into you know went
out in public one day and decided to
tell a slightly different version of
that story and instead of saying my
brother punched me in the head she said
daddy punched me in the head
that would be enough it seems to land my
kids in foster care just that sentence
if my daughter just got in it her into
her head to say that that could be it
right that's all that's it and every
parent is in this boat the only thing
keeping our parental our parental rights
intact is that our kids haven't made up
the wrong kind of story and told it to
the wrong sort of person which is
another way of saying we don't have
parental rights if you can lose them in
an instant with no evidence then what
does it even mean to say that we have
parental rights in the first place if
they can be revoked by bureaucrats at
the Child Protective Services people who
are unelected who are parently
constrained by nothing if they can come
in and just take your kids then what
does it even mean to say that you have
parental rights now I believe of course
that actual allegations of abuse have to
be investigated and and certainly we
can't ignore it
I'll do claims that they'd been abused
and some parents really are guilty of
these kinds of horrible crimes and those
parents need to be locked in prison but
due process can't go out the window
unelected unaccountable bureaucrats from
Social Services cannot be empowered to
act as prosecutor judge and jury you
know the rights of the parents have to
be preserved and respected at all times
until it has been proven proven that
they can no longer be trusted with those
rights and then the rights will be
revoked but that's not how these cases
play out here's the thing if agents of
the government are looking into
accusations against you any kind of
accusation and they're assuming your
guilt from the beginning and therefore
looking only for proof that you did
whatever they already assumed you did
rather than looking for facts on both
sides then you're screwed
that's tyranny your there's going to be
tyranny in us in a situation like that
tyranny always happens when the people
investigating an accusation assume the
guilt of the accused beforehand and
that's why presumption of innocence is
the the absolute bedrock of our justice
system is the presumption of innocence
our our philosophy in this country has
always been in principle at least in
theory has always been that it's better
to let a guilty person go free because
they were afforded the presumption of
innocence than to punish an innocent
person to punish an innocent person is
the greatest miscarriage of justice it
is the greatest travesty imaginable and
so that has to be avoided at all costs
but Child Protective Services they don't
operate that way with them the
assumption at the beginning is guilt and
then you have to dig yourself out of
that hole you have to improve your own
innocence beyond a shadow of a doubt and
if you can't do that then
your your through your finished and the
thing is the problem is if you have a
child who's telling stories who's making
things up and if you interview them with
the intent of actually figuring out what
really happened then oftentimes you'll
be able to tell that something is amiss
here and clearly this it didn't happen
how they say it happened yeah I can do
that with my own kids right if they're
tattletaling on each other most of the
time I just I don't I'm not going to get
in between it and play and you know play
the the lawyer trying to sort it out
especially when it's just frivolous
stuff but if one of my kids tells on
another on their sibling and makes a
more serious accusation that they're
they did something really unsafe or
dangerous harmful or whatever then most
of the time if I if I sit them both down
and talk to them
I can tell within like 30 seconds if
this thing actually happened or
something like it actually happened
because they're their little kids you
know they're not masterminds and usually
you can tell but if you interview them
just to get more information to prove
guilt because you've already assumed the
guilt then you're gonna ask leading
questions and you're basically going to
coax the child into making up more stuff
and I think that happens in a lot of
these situations and with kids as I've
said before in other contexts little
kids who are you know four or five years
old they don't really have any concept
of truth versus fiction of honesty verse
deception they don't understand the
distinction they really don't understand
the difference between fake and real
just conceptually they can't get their
head around it which is why a
four-year-old can never be accused of
lying
now they four-year-olds will say things
that aren't true all the time but
they're not lying
now because a lie a lie is
an intentional deception but
four-year-olds aren't trying to do that
they just they don't they get something
into their head and to them it's real
because they're thinking it that's just
how four-year-olds think that's the
psychology of it I notice this with my
kids recently when they were they were
telling me about a movie that they had
watched and I asked them I said oh is it
I was trying to figure out what movie
they're talking about and I said it was
at a cartoon it was where were they real
people and my kids they didn't
understand what I meant like they they
to distinguish between cartoons and real
they don't really do that to them it's
all real right because they're watching
it it must be real that's how kids think
and that's why it's so a situation like
this is so dangerous I mean this family
although they thank God were you know
ultimately vindicated if the DA in that
case had not exercised any prudence then
you know Adam Lau there could be in
prison right now based on whatever the
kid whatever the daughter said and it
sounds like she may have just said
something relatively innocuous which
then was was that the teacher latched on
to and then they started interviewing
her and they coaxed her into saying
things that didn't happen they just they
led her into creating this whole
fanciful fake scenario you know I when I
wrote about this on Friday I was reading
some of the comments under the under the
art I do read my comments sometimes and
there are a lot of interesting comments
people people that had a you know
experience with the Child Protective
Services and we're talking about their
own experiences which were horrifying
but then I also saw a few people that
said well who I assume are not parents
and I said I know kids would never make
something like that up I mean if you're
worried about a kid making something up
and that clearly means that you're an
abuser well these are these are
obviously not parents I mean if you if
you actually have young kids and I've
dealt with young kids you understand how
they operate
and that kids will you know they just
get something into their head and it
could be because they heard something
from a friend they saw it on TV I mean
whatever they they just they get it into
their head and they say something and
then it just snowballs from there but it
we're and we're only discussing
situations right now where a child
innocently tells a story or misinterpret
something or tries to talk about
something that really happened but
phrases it in a way that sounds you know
that sounds it makes it sound like
something it isn't but there are also
situations where a vindictive person
another adult can make it accusation
that is knowingly false I got an email
from someone talking about their own
experience they didn't want me to read
the email you know verbatim on the air
but basically they're situated first
situations like this many times where a
neighbor who didn't like them called
chop tech services and said that they
witnessed the person next door abusing
their child and it was totally made up
was composed a completely a complete lie
and that's gonna be even harder to get
yourself out of because in that case you
have an adult who is knowingly lying and
manipulating the system against you
which is really easy to do it's it's
just terrible all right one other thing
I wanted to oh yeah I wanted to also
talk about this because this is this is
interesting to me president Trump
touched off a controversy shocking to
hear I know the president Trump started
a controversy but he did when he
described on friday robert e lee as a
great general which i feel like we've
done this controversy already didn't we
I feel like we did this like a year ago
but we're doing it again he said this
while defending his previous comments
about the protests in Charlottesville a
couple of years ago sort of as an aside
while he was addressing that issue he
called robert e lee a great general and
this sent the left and
sterics as per usual with them accusing
Trump of being a racist and a neo
Confederate and so a slavery apologist
and so on and so forth
now I caught a little piece of the
ricochet from this controversy myself
because well first of all you have to
understand that I was I was when this
was going on on Friday I was flying back
from from a speech in Texas and when I
fly I get bored and so when I so what
I'm that's that's when I just start
tweeting to pass the time and it just so
happened that this whole hullabaloo was
happening while I was flying and you
know I'm interested in Civil War history
so and I'm actually reading Shelby foots
three-volume work on the on the Civil
War right now which is great by the way
so I decided to jump into the fray to
pass the time and and I said that I
agree with President Trump that robert e
lee was a great general and then I
provided my own personal ranking of the
best Civil War generals which my list
would go robert e lee Stonewall Jackson
Grant Sherman and and then Forrest
probably you could put Longstreet at
number 5 you know Sheridan you could
make an argument for anyway the point is
I also started getting backlash from the
blue checkmark Brigade on Twitter
because I ranked three Confederate
generals among the top five Civil War
generals and this is this is offensive
now apparently so let's let's get into
this a bit first of all it is absolutely
undeniable that robert e lee and
Stonewall Jackson and Longstreet and
Forrest and a number of other
Confederates or great generals I mean
that is that is that is anyone who has
studied the subject will arrive at that
conclusion that is an uncontroversial at
least it should be a none controversial
thing to say it's not a statement about
their ethics or their morals or anything
else we'll get to that part of it in a
minute but calling someone a great
general means that you're making a
statement about their abilities as a
general that's all it doesn't mean you
agree with the cause they were fighting
for
it doesn't mean you with you think they
were swell guys
it's not a it's not an endorsement of
their ethics or their or their morality
or anything like that Rommel was a great
general in World War two and he was also
a Nazi okay the fact that he was a Nazi
obviously bears heavily on any
assessment of his moral quality but it
doesn't really bear at all on an
assessment of his military prowess which
is when you're talking about great
generals that's what you're assessing
and in fact it was there were people
that were trying to challenge me and
we're saying oh so you include
Confederates in a ranking abet well if
you were ranking best World War two
generals would you include Nazis in that
list and the answer is yes of course how
good there were some great generals who
were Nazis they weren't great morally or
ethically they weren't great in any
sense except for the fact that just in
terms of their military abilities and
their strategic brilliance yes that
again anyone who has studied World War
two will say the same thing it is not a
controversial thing to say except among
idiots Oh J Simpson was a great football
player truly great no question about it
he was also a murdering sociopath is I
should say but if we were ranking you
know the best football players of the
last 40 years
Oh J Simpson is going to make the list
it it's it's not a statement of
agreement with anything that he did in
his life it's just an assessment of his
abilities as a football player you know
I happen to think that Michael Jackson
is a is a child molesting freak but if
we were talking about greatest pop stars
of all time
it would be ridiculous to leave Michael
Jackson Michael Jackson will be number
one on that list as a pop star if we
were talking about the most the most
morally upstanding people in history
Michael Jackson would definitely not be
anywhere on the list but but that has
nothing to do with his abilities as a as
a pop star
yeah the South lost the war okay
everyone
knows that robert e lee eventually
surrendered and this is often used as
proof that well they they couldn't be
great generals that they lost which of
course is stupid i mean again going back
to the football analogy it's like saying
that you couldn't possibly be a great
quarterback if you ever lost a game you
know or if you lost the Super Bowl I
mean you know there are other factors
even if you have the greatest
quarterback in the world on your team if
you don't have a defense if you don't
have an offensive line if you don't have
receivers you're not going to win very
many games there are other factors that
go into winning besides just the
quarterback and it's the same thing with
a war you know there are other factors
that fact that go into it aside from
your generals the the south they were in
these generals they were fighting an
opponent who had them out manned
outgunned outnumbered who could outlast
them in a war of attrition these
southern generals were commanding
basically shoeless farm boys who were
wielding hunting rifles and that's one
of the reasons why we have no choice but
to recognize their skills in general
ship because they were able to drag this
thing on for four years and win many
stunning battles against very long odds
think about what just Stonewall Jackson
for a minute think about what he did in
the in the valley campaign alone he
marched his men six hundred miles
through the Shenandoah Valley valley
over a month and a half won five battles
against the combined force that had him
outnumbered two to one okay does that
make him a great general yeah it does
the fact that he died after being shot
by one of his own men at
Chancellorsville that doesn't that
doesn't mean that he's not a great
general the fact that the south
eventually lost again that doesn't mean
that he's not a great general what
struck me about the reaction to what I
said and to Trump's comments is that
apparently we've reached a point where
we aren't even allowed to acknowledge
that flawed men were good at anything
like we can't acknowledge them in any
next if they were flawed we have to
pretend that they were bad at everything
and that is you can't do history that
way you can't study history that way you
can't learn from history that way you
just you can't we have to somehow
pretend that there's nothing impressive
at all about the Confederate victories
at Bull Run and second Manassas and
Chancellorsville I mean we have to
pretend that robert e lee was just some
hack right some hack who almost brought
the north to its knees with his army of
seventeen-year-old field hands well if
that's the case then this goes beyond
the Civil War
we cannot then acknowledge the greatness
of pretty much any great general that's
ever existed seeing as how none of them
would pass muster by the standards of
these preening blowhards on the left
even grant ok General Grant was an
anti-semite who tried to evict all the
Jews from his military district he also
he also married into a slaveholding
family so I guess he can't be great
and forget about Napoleon Alexander the
great Julius Caesar Patton I mean any of
these guys I don't think any of them
would would hold up to them to modern
standards for various different reasons
and so apparently none of them can be
great now it's absurd but you know I'm
actually understating I think I'm
underselling a point a little bit
because yes any literate person any
person with a middle school education or
better knows that robert e lee was a
great general that is only a
controversial statement among morons but
i would go further than that I would say
that robert e lee was a great man as
well as a great general and i know that
if people freaked out when you call him
a great general only imagine what they
would say when you call him a great man
well i I'm gonna call him a great man I
think it was a great man and I really
don't care how politically incorrect
that might be was he flawed morally yes
but he was a flawed
great man and he was far greater than
the whiny do-nothing critics who trash
his name today but have accomplished
absolutely nothing in their own lives
generally was opposed to slavery he
called it a moral evil he never
purchased a single slave and the slaves
that he inherited from his father-in-law
he eventually freed which is more than
we could be they can be said for
numerous Union generals who actually
owned slaves themselves and purchased
them themselves generally was was
opposed to secession he was offered the
job of commanding the northern army but
he declined it because as a Virginian he
could not bring himself to march an army
against his home and his sons now that
is it's not like that's a simple choice
people act like it's I well good clearly
is you should have fought for the north
well would you take up arms against your
own family would you take up arms
against your own sons against your home
maybe you would but is that really a
simple choice is that really an easy
like oh yeah sure definitely okay can we
not appreciate the the moral complexity
of the situation the robert e lee faced
that a lot of these men faced can we not
appreciate how difficult that act that
would be robert e lee was widely
respected on both sides you can read the
accounts of his surrender at Appomattox
to see just how highly regarded he was
by the men who actually did the fighting
he was one of the greatest generals this
country ever produced he was a man of
honor and dignity and you know General
Grant recognized that his soldiers
recognized that Lincoln recognized that
yet we today in modern times we cast him
aside as a racist and a traitor you know
it took 150 years for us to decide that
oh you know what actually he was a total
scumbag we can talk about the political
causes of the Civil War but it cannot be
disputed that the men who actually
fought did the fighting
they did so in their minds to protect
their countries you know southerners
considered their states to be their
countries now we made it we may not
understand that attitude nowadays but
that's the way they saw it back then
it's true that and you can you can you
should be able to understand that
because you know these days we identify
ourselves as a country we identify
ourselves with the federal government
and I'm not sure that that's really a
healthy thing to do anyway but back in
those days you know before the
Information Age before there were you
know phones and internet and highways
connecting everybody especially in the
south and agrarian society you lived off
the land you were tied to the land you
lived in your own town you didn't you
didn't travel far from it most of the
time and that was your life you know
that was your country and that's how
they saw it now it's true that one of
the primary political causes of
secession and thus the civil war was
slavery that is undeniable
but it's not true that the war was a war
over slavery you know I think to phrase
it that way would be an
oversimplification even though it is
true that the South seceded politically
in large part because of slavery
although not only because of Slayer
slavery but if you look at why the the
northern soldiers were fighting you look
at the things that that Lincoln said
they were fighting to preserve the Union
not not to end slavery and they were
very clear about that Lincoln said
himself that if he could preserve the
Union and keep slavery he would if he
could preserve the Union by getting rid
of slavery he would do that too there's
a reason why it took you know two years
for the Emancipation Proclamation to be
issued because in the early going this
was not a war to free the slaves this
was not a war over slavery and Lincoln
didn't want the the soldiers on the
ground to think that that's what they
were doing
because he knew that he wasn't gonna be
able to recruit hundreds of thousands of
soldiers if they thought they were going
off to die to free the slaves now that's
a worthy cause that's it's a it's a it's
a it is a good reason to go off and and
put yourself in harm's way but the fact
is many Northerners were just as racist
as the people in the south and they
weren't gonna fight for that reason so
for the people on the ground this was
about preserving a union for the people
in the south you know the political
leaders of the south they wanted to
secede in large part because of slavery
but for the men that were doing the
fighting they they were not slave owners
themselves the vast majority they had no
interest in slavery they considered
themselves to be fighting to protect
their homes from what they consider to
be hostile invaders ultimately slavery
stains everybody who fought for the
south there's no way around that even if
they weren't themselves fighting for
slavery even if they didn't own slaves
you know is still it does but the issue
is far more complex than we typically
make it out to be and when we look at it
in context with proper perspective I
think we can see why a man like Lee a
decent man might choose to fight for the
south because to him it was a decision
between fighting against his home or for
it that's the way that he saw it and
that's the way a lot of these people saw
it it shouldn't be difficult for us to
make that concession it again it doesn't
mean that we have to be neo Confederates
it doesn't mean that we have to support
slavery it doesn't mean that we have to
you take the side of the south or
whatever it's it's just about
understanding the complexity of a of its
of a of a war that resulted in 600,000
people but people being killed if you're
looking for simple answers and simple
you know sort of filters to look to see
it through then you're doing the wrong
thing
all right so yes great certainly a great
general and I would say great man as
well robert e lee all right uh how much
time we have okay I'll get to you know
what I'm gonna I guess we'll we'll skip
emails today and I'll do extra emails
tomorrow because there's one other thing
that I had to I can't I can't let the
show end before I show you this I have
to show you two deeply troubling video
clips okay and they're related in a way
that will soon become apparent so first
this is from the NFL Draft it's a it's a
shot of a QB finding out that he was
drafted and he's sitting with his family
and his friends and then this happens
watch this ouch that that that hurts all
right now here's another video this is
from a girl on Twitter who I guess was
surprising her friend at college or
something and I don't know it doesn't
matter but all that matters is this part
what's this
[Music]
dear Lord and and here's the thing I
could I can really relate to the to the
rejected people in both of those videos
I mean when you when you get stood up
like that honor when you get left
hanging it's hard to recover
I remember in sixth grade okay I still
remember this I have not recovered from
it in sixth grade I was I was walking
down the hallway of my school and
somebody who I thought was a friend of
mine noticed me coming down the hallway
or so I thought and and he went hey
what's up any any any and he went for
the the high five and as I was walking
towards him and I went for the high five
only to realize at the last second that
he was talking to someone behind me not
to me and so I went for the high five
but I got stood up and he went and it
left me hanging so then so that's
embarrassing enough but now in that
split second where I was where you know
I realized that the error that I had
made I started thinking okay how am I
gonna how am I gonna play this off so I
thought okay if I can play this off as
if I was trying to high-five someone
behind him then I can save face but as I
you know I'm kind of this is all
happening in like a split second so I
missed the high five and now I'm
desperately looking for someone behind
him two high five like someone that I
know like as a hey what's up
but I didn't really know anyone behind
him I sorry I just targeted this one
random kid I didn't really know that
well hey what's up he also left me
hanging so I got I got stood up on two
high fives in a row it was an absolute
catastrophe and I still have not
recovered from it and it may well had
been the defining moment of my life
III think what how might things have
gone differently if I had landed that
first high-five or even the second one
because when you miss two in a row it's
you you just can't that that's that's
your life is over basically at that
point
I've been a walking husk of a man ever
since that day so I feel I feel I feel
deeply sorry for and I and I sympathize
with the people in those videos alright
we will leave it there
thanks for watching thanks for listening
Godspeed
today on the Ben Shapiro show a new
white supremacist terror attack targets
Jews in San Diego
the New York Times reveals its
anti-semitic bias in the media rush to
defend johann omar that's today on the
bench Shapiro show